there's so many actors who you feel like
they get rewarded for their talent I
almost feel you're you get almost quasi
punished for your talent because you're
so good that the craters are this show
keep making you play okay well I think
if you played two roles or three roles
they've got you playing six rules yeah
and it feels like okay great they
recognize your talent but it's almost
like they're trying to break you yes
that's exactly what they're trying to do
yeah trying to kill me and put me in
therapy yeah yeah so what's that what I
mean for example Ryan Murphy his he
wanted you to play six different cult
leaders and he really wants you to get
inside the minds of these famous cult
leaders people like Koresh and Manson
and I mean just famous yeah sort of
psychos I would think that would be for
an actor who takes it really seriously
is really gifted that's got to be kind
of tough yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
that's all the time we have no basically
like my own little horse story I was
trying to figure out how to play all
these guys and YouTube and documentaries
and yeah you study the actual people who
were cult leaders and and and
dangerously sort of you know psychotic
people and you try and inhabit them and
they've got you I mean at one point Ryan
Murphy posted a picture of you side by
side with Manson and it was like you had
become Manson have you seen this picture
but it's really it's like it's there's
you you get almost started to look like
the people that you're playing yeah I
mean special effects did some great
prosthetics throughout the process but
yeah it was it was intense
you